in a part of the book you write the fact
that you had a chance to interview him
for the first book then when you came
out he wasn't too happy about it because
of a part of the story
can you tell us what the evolution is
from the first book to the second book
right
well i mean first of all you know the
the books are similar in one respect
you know there's just so much to learn
from amazon it is
it is almost the you know the example of
modern business and the
opportunity of disruption um and so you
know
both i think both books are are full of
revelations and lessons for students of
business so let's
let's just posit that in terms of the
company's
cooperation there it was actually very
similar maybe even a little bit better
this time in terms of you know the
company emerging from a shell
allowing me to interview senior
executives um bezos himself
was very guarded on the first book he uh
he he sort of like listened to my pitch
and then he said he didn't want to
cooperate as you mentioned uh patrick
the book came out he didn't like it for
a number of reasons including the
depiction of its corporate culture
is pretty you know tough uh and of
course i
you know feel like that's sort of been
proven out amply by time and various
testimony from employees
and then there was a personal aspect to
it which i think you're referring to
which is
i ended up tracking down his biological
father long-lost
biological father in the first book and
and that sort of
hit a little bit too close to home you
mentioned the negative review from uh
his wife at the time mackenzie
and then years passed and you know when
i came to him for this book
they they you know he and and emailed
him directly
you know he decided they decided to
cooperate he didn't give me an interview
for this book but you know i would point
to the fact that over the past few years
you know bezos has been a scarce
entity on the on the public stage at
least i mean he's obviously been out
there but in terms of interviews and
reflections
and grappling with the tough questions
around amazon he just doesn't have to do
that a lot
so that that prompts two questions right
there that
that i'll go to one of them then the
other one the first one is the
father that uh you know chasing him down
and then
you know wanting to speak with the
biological father what was that
experience like for you when you spoke
did you see a resemblance did was he
shocked i can't believe my son is doing
this what did you notice when he spoke
to
his father yeah well i mean
i'll i'll just say you know back then i
was sort of curious well what makes
what are the ingredients you know that
go into such a
unique and driven entrepreneur
entrepreneur and business
figure and you know and that is
everything from his
mentors to his early jobs and of course
to his upbringing
and you know patrick he went to his high
school years and largely grew up there
in south florida
and you know talked to friends and and
um family members
he allowed me to talk to his parents his
mother and his father who's actually
really a stepfather
and and one of the questions that i was
considering as i pursued it is you know
well okay
so where was the biological father and
had that created any kind of an absence
in his life that contributed to his
remarkable drive so
you know track down the father who was
running a bike shop in in arizona
and it turned out that the guy hadn't
known that his son had become
jeff bezos and that ended up just being
a sort of remarkable story
and a little bit of a wistful story and
tied back into the amazon story because
bezos had always run the company
with this principle of never having any
regrets and here i had tracked down the
father figure
who had been important in his very early
life then had left the family and had a
lot of regrets
so in that way it tied a bow around one
aspect to that story
yeah he talks about regret uh
minimization i think that's the word he
uses i think it's
what you use in a book the first one but
going back with
his father are you saying like his
father didn't know
that jeff was his son like you had to
find out oh so you so you had to find
out through his mom
who is his biological father and okay
walk me through that part yeah yeah now
let me clarify no he he knew he had a
son in high school
okay the couple was uh in high school he
knew that his son they were married
he was in their lives for for two or
three years after that
and then they they got divorced and he
left
and he had lost track of the family and
didn't know what had happened to the son
that he had as a kid
and didn't know if he was alive or not
and then ultimately when i knocked on
his door in 2013
didn't know that this wealthy
public-facing famous
businessman was that kid that baby
he literally had no idea no idea
no after the meeting with you and him
did he reach out to jeff edol did they
have any kind of uh interactions or
conference meetings or yeah he he tried
to reach out and
and bezos uh wrote him a note and then
he pas and then he passed away
about a year later i think so they never
met they never met up
as far as i know okay you know you know
it's interesting
and i'm curious to know what you're
saying maybe you don't have an opinion
on this maybe you do
do you notice a correlation between
uh individuals who you know there are
people that become millionaires
there are people that become
billionaires i mean you know you can
come up with a good idea become a
billionaire
but there are a few people that for
whatever
flip and reason they cannot stop
they can't even help themselves it's
this energy like
when is it going to be enough for you
when like and then you go back and you
study elon musk with the relationship
with his father you know you know
all this stuff and then you know steve
jobs mom you know hey how do you give me
up and
you know bezos father do you think there
is a correlation with one of the
parents almost not seeing like they're
gonna amount to anything how dare you
leave me that i'm gonna prove a point
the rest of my life for you to say
you weren't there do you kind of see
something like that that's why i was
curious about that but let's put it this
way uh let's not advise that an
ingredient to
uh good parenting or raising a motivated
child is to leave is to depart their
life
that's pro but and yet um i that
you know yeah i think so in some way um
you know and obviously every every kid
abandoned by a parent
is you know not going to be a high
achiever in fact probably the opposite
is true and yet in some of those cases
and you know we can look to bill clinton
or barack obama
you know when the parental figure was
missing it seemed to have been at least
one ingredient
in a remarkable ambition and and level
of achievement
and yeah that's what i was you know i'm
not a psychologist or
you know so i don't i don't really know
but certainly that's why i went down
that path
and you know and it's an open question
you know
whether that was sort of fair game right
and i don't you know and even after
all all these years i mean i'll defend
it but i think it's you know it's a good
question you know like probing into the
private life in the early life of uh of
a business figure
i mean i would say that bezos has now
had has made an impact on this
on this world to such an extent that um
you know
understanding uh from whence he came and
that elixir
you know that fueled him is is is
interesting so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]